[Musique]
des français des étrangers évacuer
d'afghanistan ont atterri en fin d'après
midi à l'aéroport de roissy charles de
gaulle dans le même temps à kaboul les
talibans ont assuré qu'ils ne
souhaitaient aucun ennemi intérieur ou
extérieur crée alors que washington
annonce négocier avec les talibans du
calendrier des évacuations américaine
pour le chef de la diplomatie de l'union
européenne il affirme qu'il faut leur
parler car ils ont gagné la guerre
[Musique]
le bilan s'alourdit après le séisme qui
a frappé l'île d'haïti ce week-end plus
de 1400 morts et près de sept mille
blessés les secours continuent de
travailler sur place pour tenter de
retrouver les survivants et porter
secours aux victimes elles des
opérations qui pourraient être perturbés
par l'arrivée d'une tempête tropicale
sur l'île
[Musique]
la manifestation aujourd'hui à marseille
de soignants opposé au pass and i ter et
à leur obligation vaccinale avant le 15
septembre
une protestation dans le sillage des
rassemblements du week-end dernier côté
sanitaire le nombre d'hospitalisations
continue d'augmenter et une nouvelle
mesure la nouvelle calédonie va rendre
la vaccination obligatoire pour entrer
sur son territoire
[Musique]
et
bonsoir à toutes et à tous il est 20h
bienvenue sur rt france et on démarre
avec l'arrivée à roissy à des premiers
française étrangers évacués de kaboul
par la france ils ont atterri en fin
d'après midi un avion a310 a transporté
45 ressortissants français et étrangers
évacués de kaboul mais aussi une
soixantaine de militaires de retour
d'opérations extérieures
depuis la base d'abu dhabi la capitale
des émirats arabes unis a précisé une
source du ministère des armées puis dans
le même temps à kaboul eh bien les
talibans donner une conférence de presse
ils ont notamment assuré qu'il
souhaitait entretenir des relations
pacifiques avec les autres pays et alors
que le procureur de la cour pénale
internationale s'inquiète des
signalements de violences dans le pays
les talibans t'assurer que la population
notamment les femmes seraient respectés
par ailleurs les insurgés ont promis ce
matin une amnistie générale pour tous
les fonctionnaires d'état retour sur les
événements de ces dernières heures avec
grégoire doucet
un semblant de retour à la normale dans
les rues de kaboul
si le choc des événements des derniers
jours reste bien présent dans les
esprits et les habitants de la capitale
afghane sortent à nouveau comme ici pour
se rendre au marché
l'objectif des taliban est à présent de
rassurer la population et c'est la
raison pour laquelle sur l'unique chaîne
de télévision publiques du pays à leur
stratégie de communication saxe en
partie sur la place des femmes dans la
société or voilà ce qu'est un homme
bozorg tallinn l'émirat islamique
d'afghanistan
estimant que les femmes ont été les
principales victimes de plus de 40 ans
de crises en afghanistan unama rate
caprasse asie beau zam zam national pour
lundi prochain et moins que l'émirat
islamique d'afghanistan ne veut plus que
ce soit le cas
l'émirat islamique d'afghanistan est
prêt à fournir aux femmes un
environnement pour travailler et étudier
et la présence des femmes dans les
différentes structures selon la loi
islamique allez on accord avec nos
valeurs culturelles
farah où
les insurgés
tu également annoncé une amnistie
générale pour leurs opposants avant leur
prise de pouvoir y compris les
responsables politiques sans toutefois
donner plus de détails selon berlin les
talibans empêchent les personnes qui
veulent quitter le territoire d'accéder
à l'aéroport de kaboul la veille ces
images avait sidéré le reste du monde à
des afghans prêt à tout pour fuir leur
pays tentait de s'accrocher à cet avion
américain décollant de la capitale
beaucoup sont restés au sol certains ont
réussi à pénétrer à l'intérieur de
l'appareil
le secrétaire général de l'otan et jens
stoltenberg s'est exprimé sur la
situation
livrant son analyse sur l'impuissance du
gouvernement afghan face aux talibans
doivent s'ils ne lance sur x au sommet
létale est ce que nous avons vu ces
dernières semaines c'est un effondrement
militaire et politique à une vitesse qui
n'avait pas été prévu une partie des
forces de sécurité afghanes ont combattu
avec courage et
tout se crée quelques
corps mais elles n'ont pas été en mesure
de sécuriser le parce qu'en fin de
compte le leadership politique afghan
n'a pas réussi à tenir tête aux talibans
et à obtenir la solution pacifique que
les accents souhaitait désespérément cet
échec des autorités afghanes est à
l'origine de la tragédie à laquelle nous
assistons réduite de tchatcher whitney
de nombreux pays exfiltre leurs
ressortissants à l'instar de la france
qui mène des opérations pour rapatrier
les quelques dizaines de citoyens
français encore présents sur place et
une autre question se pose désormais
celle de l'accueil des réfugiés afghans
sur le sol européen cet après midi la
chancelière allemande s'est exprimé à ce
sujet a écouté
je ne peux que répéter que c'est une
faiblesse de notre union européenne que
de ne pas avoir encore réussi à créer
une politique d'asile commune nous
devons continuer à y travailler avec
rigueur
avant de parler de quotas nous devons
d'abord parlé de possibilités d'accueil
et de sécurité pour les réfugiés dans
les pays voisins de l'afghanistan et
j'en discuterai également avec le haut
commissariat aux réfugiés des nations
unies dans un deuxième temps nous
pouvons réfléchir à la question de
savoir si les personnes particulièrement
vulnérables
bhl doivent venir en europe et dans les
pays européens de manière contrôlée et
avec un soutien
un accueil contrôle et donc pour angela
merkel pour emmanuel macron l'europe
elle doit se protéger contre des flux
migratoires irréguliers important des
mots lors de son allocution hier soir
des propos vivement critiqué par
l'opposition regarder
macron à parler tant que notre pays est
dans l'action de rapatriement général
devoir de solidarité nationale le temps
de la redéfinition de notre politique
internationale est venue l'élection de
2022 et ce moment sidéré d'écouté
emmanuel macron déclarant que les femmes
les hommes et les enfants qui file en
faire des talibans sont d'abord une
menace des migrants irréguliers avant
d'être des victimes et potentiellement
des réfugiés la france et l'union
européenne peuvent faire tellement mieux
macron nous devons nous protéger contre
des flux migratoires irréguliers et
l'asile et ces enfants ces femmes ces
hommes qui fuient l'horreur la france
doit prendre sa part il faut du concret
la france et l'europe doivent être
rendez vous de leur valeur de leur
histoire la protection de ces voix qui
ont porté la démocratie la liberté de
l'égalité l'état de droit doivent
pouvoir trouver refuge auprès de nous et
de son côté la russie souhaite un
dialogue de toutes les forces politiques
ethniques et confessionnelles et jugent
positive les assurances données par les
taliban ont fait le point depuis moscou
avec notre correspondantle claireaux
sergueï lavrov a commenté la situation
en afghanistan pour la première fois
depuis la prise de pouvoir par les
talibans pour le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères
ce dossier afghan démontre la nécessité
de davantage
d'interaction entre la russie et
l'occident
talk nous sommes convaincus et nous nous
sommes assurés il ya longtemps que seul
le dialogue inclusif comme on dit
communément aujourd'hui c'est à dire un
dialogue participatif qui impliquerait
toutes les forces principales peut être
vers un pas vers la normalisation de la
situation en afghanistan
aucun doute qu'il ne faut pas se laisser
guider par les critères que les états
unis et l'otan ont tenté d'y appliquer
depuis vingt ans mais s'inspirer du
respect des traditions de l'histoire et
des coutumes de tous les afghans aux
abois sur kafka le ministre russe a
poursuivi en disant que même si moscou
était ouvert au dialogue et à la
coopération cela n'avait pas valeur de
reconnaissance tout du moins pour le
moment
nous en avons déjà parlé à plusieurs
reprises nous nous empressons pas de le
reconnaître comme tous les autres pays
pas plus tard qu'hier j'ai parlé avec le
ministre des affaires étrangères de la
république populaire de chine wang li
nos positions coïncident nous voyons des
signes encourageants de la part des
talibans qui déclarent leur volonté de
former un gouvernement avec la
participation d'autres forces politiques
qui se déclare prêt à poursuivre les
processus y compris ceux liés à
l'éducation l'éducation des filles est
en général avec le fonctionnement de
l'appareil d'état sans fermer la voie
aux fonctionnaires qui ont travaillé
sous le précédent gouvernement du
président gagne
même si elle est ouverte à la
coopération la russie ainsi que ses
alliés d'asie centrale suivent de très
près la nouvelle donne à kaboul une
nouvelle donne qui pourrait avoir de
lourdes conséquences sur la stabilité de
cette région du monde et joe biden s'est
également exprimée hier soir il a
affirmé ne pas regretter le départ des
troupes américaines pour le lieutenant
steven rogers ses 20 ans d'intervention
débouche sur un fiasco écouter
et à l'objectif était de s'assurer que
le gouvernement afghan soit fort que ce
soit un pays où les gens seraient libres
un pays amené dernier par une
constitution et non pas par un dictateur
ou une organisation terroriste
l'objectif n'a jamais été atteint les 20
ans de travail ont été prodigués ce que
nous avons vu être une catastrophe
comment peut-on abandonné pour ces gens
derrière nous je parle des citoyens
afghans qui connaîtront détention
d'enfants et des meurtres
on a ici la présence quatre jours après
le terrible séisme qui a frappé l'île le
bilan ne cesse de s'alourdir plus de
1400 morts et près de sept mille blessés
les équipes de secours continuent leur
travail sur place pour tenter de
retrouver des survivants d'une tâche
perturbée par de fortes pluies et des
vents violents les précipitations
pourraient atteindre 38 cm dans
certaines région déjà dévastée par le
séisme des milliers de personnes se
retrouvent sans abri les précisions avec
solène gaudin
des blessés qui s'entassent dans la cour
de l'hôpital
soigner avec les moyens du bord
aux cayes en haïti les soignant tentent
de faire face à l'afflux de victimes du
tremblement de terre de samedi dernier
hier c'était vraiment dieu on n'avait
pas de personnel mais on a bien géré la
situation ont fait de même pour
aujourd'hui pour bien gérer la situation
pour notre population
les patients les plus gravement blessés
sont transportés à bord d'hélicoptères
des garde-côtes américains vers les
centres de soins de port au prince la
capitale
l' agence de protection civile poursuit
ses recherches de survivants dans les
décombres de la ville engloutie par le
séisme en tout plus de trente sept mille
habitations ont été détruites des
milliers de personnes se retrouvent sans
abri pour leur venir en aide les états
unis l'équateur la république
dominicaine ou encore le mexique ont
envoyé des colis alimentaires et du
matériel d'urgence dès dimanche ce lundi
le président mexicain s'est engagé à
soutenir haïti face à cette catastrophe
n'a calendaire assassinat le président
vient d'être assassiné la situation est
très instable et ce séisme est un autre
malheur qui s'abat sur un population
appauvrie en train les glaces nous avons
décidé de les soutenir et nous
continuerons à le refaire
on m'annonce s arena
de lui et rien de ce qui est humain ne
nous est étranger oublions les
frontières c'est qu'ils vont appliquer
le principe de la fraternité universelle
elle principe bien de la fraternité une
aide humanitaire qui s'achemine dans
l'urgence à la proche d'un cyclone qui
menace d'aggraver encore la situation
en france des soignants marseillais se
rassemblent contre le pass sanitaires et
l'obligation vaccinale ils étaient une
cinquantaine réunis devant l'hôpital de
la timone un rendez vous hebdomadaire
que les soignants décidé de tenir et
dans les hôpitaux le manque de personnel
continue de se faire ressentir et avec
le pass sanitaires beaucoup de soignants
déjà quitté le monde de la santé les
revendications sont aussi liées au
manque de reconnaissance et aux
conditions de travail et coûté
je suis pas contre le vaccin mais ce qui
me gêne beaucoup c'est le fait du pass
sanitaire qui ne respectent plus le
secret médical et ça m'a écouté toute ma
vie professionnelle on m'a dit secret
médical on ne doit pas divulguer
notamment les ordonnances que les gens
comme maladie est là maintenant on nous
fait avoir un pasa knitter que des
simples vigile qui a aucune notion
médicale j'ai rien contre les vigiles
contre les gens les agents de sécurité
mais des gens qui n'ont aucune notion
médicale vont demander le qr code alors
sur votre portable sur le papier mais de
quel droit ces gens là doivent savoir
mon état de santé donc aujourd'hui ce
gouvernement alors que nous étions
fortement mobilisés avant la pandémie
n'a toujours pas répondu aux légitimes
revendications du personnel on a
toujours aujourd'hui on ferme des smur
et des urgences par manque d'effectif
j'ai des unités qui sont impactés
gravement et qui mettent en péril un
certain nombre de prises en charge et
derrière il ya toujours la réforme du
statut de la fonction publique avec fin
des chsct baisse des prérogatives
syndicales et on souffre toujours à
l'hôpital le monde d'après les pires que
celui d'avant
nous faire prendre des risques
pendant tout le début de la pandémie
sans équipements de protection
individuelle est là maintenant on serait
les mauvais
élèves c'est non seulement c'est une
mise c'est une atteinte à la liberté
mais c'est une hypocrisie pas possible
du gouvernement qui impose de ne pas se
salit terre en se disant non la
vaccination n'est pas obligatoire mais
en scène pour vivre il va falloir
présenté à tout-va notre pass sanitaires
pour aller faire des courses à voyage
pour aller au cinéma au théâtre dans les
musées de qui se moque t-on corps un
rassemblement marseille dans le sillage
des mobilisations de samedi contre le
pass sanitaires près de deux cent quinze
mille personnes y ont participé selon le
ministère de l'intérieur une
mobilisation marquée par certains
débordements dénoncé par l'exécutif le
gouvernement qui maintient le cap on
voit cela avec lucas léger
la majorité silencieuse contre la foule
bruyante depuis des temps immémoriaux
les dirigeants s'en sont prévalus dans
les périodes de turbulences où leur
autorité été remise en question la macro
ni elle a trouvé une variante aux
concepts opposés la majorité silencieuse
vacciner aux manifestants contre le
passage ni terre plus ou moins réduit un
statut d'anti vague grincheuse est
opposée à la science un peu comme si le
fait de se faire injecter un vaccin
revenait à voter oui à référendum sur la
politique sanitaire du gouvernement dès
le départ des manifestations le pouvoir
a mis en place sa stratégie de
communication consistant à
systématiquement minimiser l'ampleur du
mouvement comparé aux millions de
français vaccinés les chiffres de
mobilisation à retenir aujourd'hui ce
sont près de 45 millions de français qui
ont reçu au moins une injection et les
37 millions de français désormais
protégés cette mobilisation la sauve des
vies par ailleurs l'apparition de
pancartes ouvertement antisémite brandie
par des militants d'extrême droite
présents dans certains cortèges ou des
références à l'occupation et au nazisme
ont soulevé de forte indignation dans
l'opinion publique vous avez deux cent
mille personnes qui ont manifesté à
samedi pour dire qu'il voulait pas du du
vaccin avec des des pancartes
extrêmement bariolés et des motifs
parfois extrêmement douteux
permettez-moi de le dire voire
complètement complètement crade
ces packs à tout le monde mais on en a
vu beaucoup moi je pense que le
gouvernement comprend que ce mouvement
n'est pas caricatural mais il essaye de
le caricaturer si vous regardez dans les
manifestations le profil des gens
vous n'avez pas des fous vous avez des
gens du quotidien quoi donc c'est pour
ça qu'on veut à tout prix et caricaturer
ce moment moi je pense très sincèrement
que ce mouvement c'est parce qu'il est
difficilement caricatural qu'on essaye
d'en faire des tonnes sur encore une
fois cette affaire de pancartes par
exemple à la rentrée on va avoir la
rentrée sociale on va avoir également la
vaccination des plus jeunes ont donc
tous à conjuguer la sphère que vous
allez avoir énormément de gens dans la
rue et c'est ça ce qu'ils craignent
pendant le mouvement des gilet jaune qui
est souvent comparé à celui contre le
pass sanitaire radicalité la violence de
certains manifestants avaient largement
été exploité par l'exécutif que certains
prennent pour prétexte de parler au nom
du peuple et n'étant en fait que les
porte voix d'une foule haineuse s'en
prennent aux élus aux forces de l'ordre
aux journalistes aux juifs aux étrangers
aux homosexuels
c'est tout simplement la négation de la
france samedi dernier il ya eu selon les
chiffres très contestée du ministère de
l'intérieur moins de manifestants dans
les rues pour la première fois depuis le
début du mouvement contre le pass
sanitaire mais le chiffre est encore
très important pour une veille de 15
août et dans les rues le slogan
principal reste liberté une
revendication qui peut toucher un public
nettement plus large que les antilles
vague sur les radicaux de tous bords et
ce public malgré le mépris du
gouvernement pourrait bien devenir de
plus en plus urticants alors que la
course à la présidentielle commence à
poindre à l'horizon et depuis le début
de l'épidémie plusieurs scientifiques
parlent d' immunité collective elle
serait hors d'atteinte selon plusieurs
médecins en cause la propagation rapide
de plusieurs variants en revanche ils
soutiennent que la vaccination limite la
circulation du virus et les formes
graves le point en images
même les plus optimistes commencent à en
douter l'immunité collective serait
inatteignable la faute notamment à la
circulation des variants début août alan
fisher évoqué la possibilité d'atteindre
l'immunité collective à l'automne quinze
jours plus tard le président du conseil
d'orientation de la stratégie vaccinale
change d'avis c'est l'immunité de groupe
peut être atteinte ou non je ne sais pas
c'est devenu un challenge très ambitieux
que je ne trancherai pas on l'estimé à
60 puis à 80% à cause du variant alpha
maintenant et selon des modélisations le
seuil de l'immunité collective a été
réhaussée à plus de 90% de la population
vaccinée le variant delta plus
résistants au vaccin est majoritaire sur
le territoire français est la cause
principale de ce changement pour yves
buisson la vaccination massive reste la
solution pour en finir avec l'épidémie
si on vaccine toute la population quand
bien même le virus circule un peu et
passe d'une personne à une autre il aura
beaucoup de difficultés à passer à une
troisième personne il va s'éteindre très
vite en france les rendez vous pour se
faire vacciner sont en chute libre
les médecins continuent malgré tout de
rappeler l'importance de la vaccination
à la fin du mois de juillet 85 % des
personnes admises en soins critiques
n'étaient pas vaccinées en france est
depuis le 15 juin la vaccination est
ouverte aux adolescents
l'extension aux moins de 12 ans fait
actuellement l'objet d'une réflexion au
sein de l'exécutif
alors que l'algérie est un ces derniers
foyers après les incendies meurtriers de
la semaine dernière qui ont coûté la vie
à près de 90 personnes la police a
ouvert une enquête après le lynchage
d'un homme de 38 ans accusé à tort
d'être l'un des pyromanes présumés chez
les précisions de notre correspondant
bassam chez bis c'est une affaire qui
prend de l'ampleur en algérie qui fait
le tour des réseaux sociaux des images
chocs d'un jeune homme lynché par la
foule aux abords d'un commissariat de
larba nath irathen près de tizi ouzou en
kabylie région du nord de l'algérie en
proie à de violents incendies qui ont
coûté la vie à près de 90 personnes pour
moi m shakur le directeur de la police
judiciaire djamel bensmaïl 38 ans
s'était rendu à la police par lui même
après avoir entendu qu'on le soupçonnait
d'avoir mis le feu à une forêt une foule
en colère s'étaient alors amassé aux
abords du commissariat de police bien
décidés à en découdre avec celui qu'on
soupçonnait d'être à tort l'un des
pyromanes là victime a été battue puis
brûlé parmi les 36 suspects interpellés
par la police l'individu qui a poignardé
la victime a été arrêté tandis qu'il
tentait de fuir vers le maroc a déclaré
le directeur de la police judiciaire
lors d'une conférence de presse
soulignant que l' enquête était toujours
en cours un traumatisme selon la ligue
algérienne de défense des droits de
l'homme alors que le père de la victime
a été massivement salués à travers tout
le pays après avoir appelé au calme et à
la fraternité entre algériens alors que
le pays exige que la justice se fasse
toute la lumière sur cette affaire qui a
choqué toute une nation ce week-end
encore pompiers militaires et
volontaires ont continué d'éteindre les
derniers feux de forêts qui ravagent la
kabylie depuis lundi dernier et la
communauté franco algérienne
s'organisent pour aider l'algérie après
ces feux depuis plusieurs jours elle se
démène pour envoyer des dons notamment
des médicaments pour aider les victimes
des incendies qui ont touché la kabylie
mais aussi celle du co vite 19 reportage
à toulouse de valentin carpentier et de
hervé grandchamp donc à la biafine pour
les patients brûlés il ya des compresses
stériles
des cartons remplis de médicaments
cela fait des jours que merouane mais
c'est clair les empilent interne au chu
de toulouse mais roanne est aussi
président de médical up
créée le 10 août dernier son association
propose de faire des dons de médicaments
et de produits sanitaires pour aider
l'algérie à faire face à la pandémie de
kovy 19 et au violent incendie qui la
touche depuis plusieurs jours un appel
rapidement entendu les réponses des
toulousains étaient vraiment rapides
donc nous avons commencé à récupérer des
dons dès le jour on a lancé cet appel
aux dents et les gens continuent de
venir tous les jours soit pour donner
sur place soit il on voit par voie
postale des chèques ou des dons
matériels
en une semaine l'association a récolté
un très grand nombre de dons un local de
20 mètres carrés ainsi déjà été remplies
et un troisième centre de collecte de
dons a été ouvert ce lundi hakima denis
s'est porté volontaire pour le tenir
giran d'une brasserie à toulouse il
laisse à disposition son établissement
pour y entreposer les dons avant qu'il
soit envoyé en algérie et rapidement
l'idée de faire quelque chose pour pour
pour la kabylie pour l'algérie en
général est venu et finalement le c'est
l'association qui a pris contact avec
moi pour me dire qu'il cherchait un
endroit pour entreposer des médicaments
des dents et comme on est si tu es
vraiment un centre ville c'était avec un
grand plaisir que j'ai accepté et que
j'essaie de les aider à collecter ces
médicaments et à aider les nôtres en
algérie comme toulouse de nombreuses
villes ont rejoint le mouvement
plusieurs cagnotte ont également été
créés et celle de merouane avait pour
objectif 650000 euros une somme presque
déjà atteinte en à peine une semaine
et l'actualité c'est aussi à suivre sur
rt france point tv à lire aujourd'hui
sur notre site un centre de six nations
à toulouse vandalisé la nuit dernière
pour total 500 doses antico vides ont
été détruites aucune revendication n'a
été observé sur place le centre devrait
reprendre ses activités d'ici la fin de
la semaine l'enquêté confiée à la
section de recherches de la dina
[Musique]
et loire snowdon dénonce les propos du
président français les comparant à ceux
de la présidente du rassemblement
national marine le pen
le lanceur d'alert critique notamment la
volonté d' emmanuel macron de vouloir
protéger la france contre les fous
migratoires irréguliers important
n'est plus un avion de transport
militaire s'est écrasé près de moscou la
nuit dernière les trois personnes
présentes à bord sont décédées selon les
autorités l'accident s'est produit lors
d'un vol d'entraînement
en juillet dernier le vice premier
ministre avait déjà déclaré des
problèmes liés à la conception ce type m
tensions diplomatiques entre la pologne
et israël à samedi les autorités
polonaises ont adopté une loi qui aurait
selon l'état hébreu pour conséquence de
bloquer les restitution de biens dont
des victimes de la shoah ont été spoliés
celle les explications en images
[Musique]
ce soir la pologne est devenue un pays
anti démocratique qui n'honorent pas la
plus grande tragédie de l'histoire
humaine
[Musique]
tant que je serai premier ministre la
pologne ne payera certainement pas pour
les crimes allemand
nous prendrons les bonnes décisions
concernant ses voyages nous sommes
confrontés un sentiment anti polonais en
israël
[Musique]
et c'est la fin de cette édition merci
de l'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actualité dans une trentaine de
minutes rester avec nous sur rt france a
totalement
[Musique]
en suisse un fonctionnement politique
très particulier
elle permet à ses citoyens de se
prononcer sur les lois temps proposé et
même de les faire retirer éventuellement
en suisse il ya nos outils le premier il
permet d'attaquer les lois l'autre
instrument